A Monolithic structure definitely gives you protection,
no questions about that. And we also
argued that it's performant because of the
fact that border crossings are minimized and loss
of locality is minimized. And, and sources
of copying overhead are minimized. All of that
add up to giving good performance for
the Monolithic structure. On the other hand It's
not easily extensible. Any change to
the operating system would require rebuilding
the monolithic structure with the changed
characteristic of the system service. So, one
size fits all is what you get with a monolithic structure. A DOS-like structure
is performant because there is no separation between the application and
the operating system and, therefore, an application
can execute system services at the same speed
as it would execute a procedure call that
is part of that application itself. And it's
also easily extensible because you can build
new versions of system service. To cater to
the needs of specific applications. But on the
other hand, it fails on the safety attribute.
Because there is no boundary separating the
kernel from the user space. A micro-kernel
based operating system also. Pays attention to
protection because it makes sure that the applications
and the servers are in distinct hardware
address spaces separated from the microkernel itself
and it is also easily extensible because
you can have different servers that provide the
same service. But differently to cater to the needs of the application but it
may have performance flaws because of the
need for so many border crossing that might
be needed to go between applications and the server processes. Having said that
I want to give a note of caution, on the surface it may appear That the
microkernel based approach may not be performant because of the potential for
frequent border crossings. I'll have a surprise for you on this aspect when we
discuss the L3 microkernel later on in this course module where it is shown that
a microkernel. Can be made performant by careful implementation, that's the key.
I'll leave you with that thought, but we'll come back
to a micro kernal base design using L3 later on.